es 3 menos 4 una solución de la ecuación
5 x 2 7 hay dos maneras de hacer esto la
primera es sustituir estos valores de xy
en la ecuación y ver si la satisface eso
es lo que vamos a hacer primero y la
otra manera es si tienes la gráfica de
esta ecuación puedes ver si este punto
se encuentra sobre la gráfica de la
ecuación
lo cual va a significar que es solución
de la ecuación hagamos el primer método
tenemos la ecuación 5 x 2
7 entonces tenemos 5 x x en este caso x
es igual a 3 que se base el valor de x
entonces va a ser 5 x 3 más vamos a
sumarle dos veces el valor de y dos
veces el valor de ye que es menos cuatro
más dos veces menos cuatro y esto tiene
que ser igual a 7 queremos verificar si
esto se cumple bien hagamos las
operaciones del lado izquierdo del lado
izquierdo tenemos 5 por 3 es 15
luego 2 x menos 4 es menos 8 entonces
esto sería 15 8 y tenemos que verificar
que 15 menos 8 sea igual a 7 y
efectivamente 15 menos 8 es igual a 7
así es que esto se cumple y la respuesta
es sí si es solución de la ecuación
hemos encontrado la solución por el
método de sustitución vamos a graficar
la ecuación para encontrar la solución
por el método gráfico hagamos entonces
la gráfica lo que voy a hacer es una
tabla de valores hay varias maneras de
encontrar la gráfica podríamos poner
esta ecuación en la forma punto
pendiente pero lo que yo voy a hacer es
una tabla de valores xy los cuales
graficar y veremos si el punto 3 menos 4
se encuentra sobre la recta podríamos
graficar directamente el punto 3 como
menos 4 y vamos a ver que efectivamente
se encuentran sobre la recta ya vimos
que es una solución pero no lo voy a
hacer por el momento simplemente voy a
dar valores para obtener una gran así
entonces si x es igual a 0 5 por 0 es
igual a 0 más dos porque igual a 7 si
dos por y es igual a 7 que tiene que ser
52 por 3.5 es igual a 7 así es que es
igual a 3.5 3.5 tomemos ahora el valor
de x igual a 1 si x es igual a 1 aquí
tenemos 5 x 1 + 2 porque es igual a 7
ver veamos 5 2 igual a 7 pasamos el 5
restando el otro lado 2 y es igual a 2
que va a ser igual a 1 cuando x es igual
a 1 que es igual a 1 ahora hagamos x
vamos x igual bueno de hecho con estos
dos puntos podemos graficar la recta
podríamos tener más puntos de hecho
podemos tener el punto tres coma menos
cuatro aquí pero con estos dos puntos ya
es suficiente para poder graficar
grossomodo una recta así es que hagamos
nuestro eje x y aquí vamos a tener
nuestro eje y nuestro eje vertical que
es nuestro eje y vamos a poner la escala
aquí tenemos uno
3 4 y menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 y vamos a
poner nuestra escala para x tendríamos 1
es esta muy grande 1 2 3 4 5 6 esto es
para x vamos a graficar entonces los
puntos el punto cero 3.50 123 3.5 aquí
está y el punto 1,1 el punto 11 que
tenemos por aquí y así ya puedo
construir la recta lo voy a hacer con
una línea punteada para conectar más
fácilmente los puntos déjame hacerlo
mejor dejamos el mejor en la recta
construimos entonces nuestra línea recta
de tal manera que podemos checar si el
punto 3 menos 4 está en la recta para
esto necesito trazar una mejor recta voy
a tomar una nueva oportunidad de trazar
una mejor recta vamos entonces a trazar
una mejor recta
de tal manera que aquí tenemos vamos a
hacer un mejor trabajo con esto de tal
manera que al conectar los puntos
tenemos la recta entonces si quiero ver
si el punto 3 como menos 4 se encuentra
sobre la recta ubicó x igual a 3 y veo
si sobre la recta a un valor de x igual
a 3 corresponde un valor de ye igual a
menos 4 y efectivamente tenemos el punto
3 coma menos 4 obviamente en general no
vas a confiar simplemente en la
inspección de la gráfica quizás al ver
la gráfica tú ves un valor de menos 3.99
por lo cual te quedaría duda con tan
sólo ver la gráfica es por eso que
tienes que ir directamente a la ecuación
para que cuando sustituye los valores de
xy verificas que se cumple la igualdad
no tan sólo por ver la gráfica pero es
importante darse cuenta que la gráfica
es otra representación de todas las
soluciones de esta ecuación